THIS IS MY MOST DISTURBING DAY
IN CONGRESS, IT'S HARD TO SEE
THE MOST DISTURBING THING I'VE
HEARD BECAUSE SO MANY THINGS
I'VE HEARD ARE DISTURBING.
>> I THINK WE AGREE.
IT'S THIS TIME.
WHAT THE HELL HAPPENED LAST
WEEK.
WAS IT A FINANCIAL CRASH, NO THE
STOCK MARKET HIT A RECORD HIGH,
WAS THERE SOME KIND OF TERROR
ATTACK, NOT REALLY.
A POPULAR ONE FOR WE TOOK AT THE
HEAD OF ISIS.
WHAT IS THIS CRISIS.
IT IS ABOUT PUTTING NATIONAL
SECURITY AT RISK.
CORRUPTION, ABUSE OF POWER THAT
DAMAGED AND NATIONAL SECURITY.
>> IT'S ABOUT NATIONAL SECURITY
RETURNED TO THE ONE PERSON WHO
IS SMART AND SHARP ENOUGH TO
EXPLAIN THE DANGEROUS NATIONAL
SECURITY A CRISP AND CLEAR WAY.
>> THE IDEA THAT SOMEONE WOULD
INVADE THE FOREIGN POWER INTO
OUR ELECTION AND IN THE PROCESS
WITHHOLD APPARENTLY THE
ALLEGATION IN SOME WITHIN THE
ADMINISTRATION HEARD THE
CONVERSATIONS WITHHOLD VITAL
AID, MILITARY AID VOTED FOR BY
THE CONGRESS WHILE UKRAINIANS
ARE DYING IN THE EASTERN
UKRAINE.
IN ORDER TO TAKE ON RUSSIAN TOUR
THERE STILL KILLING THEM IS ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT NO PRESIDENT
I'M AWARE OF HAS EVER THOUGHT OF
DOING WAKE UP HE FINISHED.
AND NO PRESIDENT EVER THOUGHT
WASN'T THAT -- I THINK THERE WAS
ONE PRESIDENT WHO DID THAT.
WHO WAS IT, I REMEMBER.
IT WAS THE SKY.
THAT IS OKAY.
IT WAS YEARS AGO.
IT WAS NOT JUST JOE BIDEN WHO IS
CONVENIENTLY FORGETTING.
IT'S ALL THE DEMOCRATS AND
BUREAUCRATS AND ALL ON THE HIGH
HORSE OF DAMAGING NATIONAL
SECURITY BY NOT SENDING PROPER
MILITARY AID TO UKRAINE EVEN
THOUGH HE DID SEND IT AND OBAMA
DIDN'T.
THIS HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
NATIONAL SECURITY, IS ALL JUST
AN ILLUSION.
A BOMB SAW REVELATION.
SO SHOCKING AND DISTURBING THAT
THE DEMOCRATS ARE RULING ABOUT
LAST WEEK AND IT'S NOTHING WE
DID NOT ALREADY KNOW.
THE TRUTH ABOUT THIS IMPEACHMENT
IS IT'S NOT ABOUT FINDING OUT
AND WE DID NOT KNOW IT'S ABOUT
TELLING A STORY, A HIGHLY
POLITICAL STORY AND THEY'VE
SETTLED ON THE CONCERT
CHARACTERS.
>> TAYLOR, OF OTTOVICH, TAYLOR,
THEN MEN.
>> FIONA HILL.
>> DO JOVANOVICH.
>> TAYLOR.
>> THE ANTI-TRUMP CULT NOW
RECITES THE NAMES OF THESE
BUREAUCRATS TAYLOR, THEN MEN,
FIONA HILL.
AS WE KEEP REMINDING THEY'VE
WORKED AT THE HEART, IRAN POLICY
OF ALL TIMES.
AND PLEASE TELL THEM THEY HATE
POLITICAL BACK CHANNELS BECAUSE
IT TAKES AWAY FROM THE POWER TO
CONTROL POLICY.
THEY USE EVERY TRICK IN THE BOOK
OF THE POLITICAL INVOLVEMENT
THAT IS ILLEGITIMATE.
THEY ARE ACTING ILLEGITIMATELY
AND THEY HAVE NO LEGITIMATE
MANDATE EXCEPT FOR ONE GIVEN TO
THEM BY THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
DEMOCRATICALLY ELECTED AND THERE
IS ONLY ONE PERSON WITH THAT
DESCRIPTION AND ITS PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
REMEMBER THE SERVANTS WHO WERE
IN A TV PUT ON A PEDESTAL.
IN THE ELITE THAT HAS BEEN WRONG
ON EVERY MAJOR ISSUE FOR THE
LAST 30 YEARS, I'D RATHER TAKE
ADVICE FROM THE CHICKENS IN MY
BACKYARD THEN WASHINGTON FOREIGN
POLICY ESTABLISHMENT.
MY CHICKENS ARE VERY SMART.
AND VERY CUTE.
BUT THERE WAS ONE NAME MISSING
FROM THE IMPEACHMENT FANATICS
CHARACTER LAST WEEK.
THIS MAN, KURT VOLKER, HE WAS
THERE JUST LIKE THE OTHERS
GIVING OUT A TESTIMONY, THE
TRANSCRIPT OF HIS EVIDENCE WAS
RELEASED LAST WEEK BUT NOT A
PEEP ABOUT VOLKER.
I WONDER WHY.
COULD IT BE BECAUSE AS I POINTED
OUT WHEN WE READ HIS WITNESS
STATEMENT, HE EXULTED THE
PRESIDENT ON THE NAME
IMPEACHMENT CHARGES.
THIS WEEK I READ THE TRANSCRIPT,
THE VOLKER TRANSCRIPT ON PAGE
36, HE CLAIMS THERE WAS NO
LINKING BETWEEN THE
INVESTIGATION AND ON PAGE 41 HE
EXPLAINED HE ADVISES PRESIDENT
TRUMP, NOT THE PRESIDENT WHO
COOKED UP THE IDEA OF GETTING
UKRAINIANS TO MAKE A STATEMENT
ABOUT THE BIDENS IN ORDER TO GET
PRESIDENT TRUMP TO VIEW THE
PRESIDENT MORE FAVORABLE.
PAGE 47, IT WAS UKRAINIANS WHO
WANTED TO BE CONNECTED TO RUDY
GIULIANI, PAGE 79 VOLKER SAYS
MILITARY AID WAS HELD UP FOR A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT REASONS, ON
AND ON IT GOES.
PAGE AFTER PAGE, 360 PAGES
EXHILARATING THE PRESIDENT.
BUT SOMEHOW DESPITE BEING ONE OF
THE PRECIOUS CREW DIPLOMATS, HE
BARELY MENTIONED KURT VOLKER'S
TESTIMONY LAST WEEK AND THE
DEMOCRATS HAVEN'T INVITED HIM TO
THE PUBLIC HEARING NEXT WEEK AND
HE TOLD THE PEOPLE AT THE RALLY,
READ THE TRANSCRIPT
READ THE T-SNSCRIPT
READ THE T-SHICRIPT
READ THE T-SHIRTIPT
READ THE T-SHIRT AT
READ THE T-SHIRT AS READ THE
TRANSCRIPT AND THE PRESIDENT
CALL, READ THE VOLKER
TRANSCRIPT.
IT SHOWS THIS WHOLE IMPEACHMENT
IS A THOUGHT.
NO NORMAL PERSON CARES ABOUT ANY
OF THIS.
WE ARE REALLY IN THE WEEDS WHEN
WERE ABANDONING THE NAME OF
SCREWED BUREAUCRATS THEN WENT